total nightmare there's only one person
happy about the airport mass and the
massive pileups of luggage at all these
airports and that's Sam Britain and the
truth is everything about this crisis
was foreseeable in August 38 State
Attorneys General rode to Congress to
report that Pete Buddha judge was
ignoring consumer complaints in the
airline industry unfortunately the
agency has thus far failed to respond
the attorney generals wrote they were so
outraged that they called on Congress to
strip the Department of Transportation
of the ability to oversee customer
complaints against the Airlines and
awarded it to the states themselves
that's not it's not hard to see why
those attorneys generals were so Furious
without reliable air travel the economy
collapses and mirp was ignoring the
problem he was able to do that because
despite his fixation on climate change
Buddha judge flies everywhere on private
jet with striking is how often this
happens there's a crisis and people the
judge decides to ignore it mayor Pete
went on vacation in Portugal just a
couple weeks ago as rail workers
prepared to strike he was on paternity
leave as dozens of container ships
couldn't enter the country a year ago
and mayor Pete hasn't even mentioned
this horrifying story of a woman
freezing to death in her car just before
Christmas while driving home from work
Buddha judge loves to talk about racist
roads but he hasn't mentioned this
tragedy at all here's an NBC report
people walking the streets with
sidewalks submerged days after the
deadliest storm in the city's history
now more than 30 dead in Western New
York among them Andel Taylor her sisters
say she was one of the best sisters yeah
daughters friends
all right you could ever have Taylor's
sister says she pulled over on her drive
home from work Friday with the storm
bearing down they say Taylor took these
videos in her final hours calling 9-1-1
for help that didn't make it in time a
resident finding her dead the day before
Christmas as endell Taylor was sitting
in her car for hours she texted with
family members about the long wait for
help Taylor's sister couldn't believe
New York officials were so caught off
guard by the blizzard she texted quote
unsurprised in a state known for it or
unprepared and to stay known for it more
than 35 people died during the Buffalo
blizzard many of them had been stranded
like andele Taylor without any
assistance from First Responders this is
a massive failure of state and federal
leadership but instead of acknowledging
that Pete Buddha judge he's ignoring it
for her part New York's Governor Kathy
hokel is blaming you guessed it climate
change she says it's making the weather
far more dangerous but the truth is that
the number of people dying from natural
disasters particularly storms and
extreme temperatures is plummeted in the
last century that's because competent
leadership
responds to these disasters and
minimizes the loss of life and human
suffering but incompetent leaders
leaders like Joe Biden they vacation in
the Virgin Islands and ignore disasters
that's why the Texas border now looks
like this
today Fox cameras capturing hundreds of
migrants in four separate groups
Crossing into the U.S at the southern
Border in Eagle Pass Texas
hundreds of miles to the Northwest in El
Paso a wire fence rapidly erected and
hundreds of military personnel are in
place to prepare for a potentially
explosive surge of migrants also in El
Paso this massive tent larger than a
football field set up by U.S Customs and
Border Protection will act as a
processing center if there is a surge
with freezing temperatures shelters
there are full migrants have been
sleeping on the streets with donated
blankets
weeks ago before I went on vacation Joe
Biden was asked why doesn't visit the
southern border there's more important
things going on Biden said now as
expected hundreds of thousands of
illegal migrants are flooding the border
into a country that's already becoming
more third world like every day people
are freezing to death in their cars and
air travel isn't even close to Reliable
you have to ask if this Administration
wanted to overwhelm and sabotage what's
left of the country's infrastructure
what exactly would they do differently
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight